Yep.
He has got an image problem for years.
This gigantic country,
the second most populated in all of
Africa with almost a hundred million
inhabitants with a synonym for extreme
poverty,
hunger,
disease,
war in short,
true misery.
However,
in the new century,
everything began to change.
Even though Ethiopia is still a very
poor country in the last decade,
it has become one of the fastest growing
economies,
not only in Africa but in the world at
the same time.
It has grown very close to Beijing and
has also become a close ally of the
United States in the fight against
terrorism.
Why half face single friendship if you
can have both.
The fact is that we're probably
witnessing nothing more or less because
I'm the birth of a future African power
and that's more than enough reason to
ensure that we hear on visual politic
don't want to miss what's happening in a
country that many are already calling
the new African China.
So listen up after decades of tension,
hostility and confrontation before ends,
after Eritrea gained independence from
Ethiopia in 1993 on July the ninth of
2018 both countries signed a declaration
for peace and we should remember that
during this long confrontation,
they were tragic moments.
Indeed,
the military conflicts between 98 and
2000 kills nearly a hundred thousand
people.
Now,
the leaders of both countries,
they've agreed to sign for complete
peace.
We had agreed to resume the services of
our airlines to get our ports working,
to get our people to trade and to open
our embassies again.
There is no longer a border between
Eritrea and Ethiopia because of bridge
of love has destroyed it.
I be on that Ethiopia's prime minister,
but of course the question remains what
has led these two countries to suddenly
like each other so much?
Well,
my friends,
even though it may seem incredible,
one of the problems that prevented
reconciliation was this village that you
see on the screen now.
It's bothering me and it's a place where
there's practically nothing at all.
And do you see based on the peace
agreements that were negotiated in our g
as in the year 2000 to ends,
the last war,
this territory belongs to Eritrea.
In the end,
the Ethiopian government realize that
this didn't work for them,
so those peace agreements didn't really
go anywhere until the now,
now Ethiopia,
the stronger country between the two,
after all,
we're talking about a hundred million
people against just over 5 million
they've decided to give up because if
you are on many occasions persisting
just to look stronger is a mistake.
That's bad for everyone.
There's nothing to gain and there's a
great deal to lose in any case of this
piece is a good reflection of the
changes that are taking place and is not
because this might surprise you.
Okay.
Chinese model,
recent years,
Ethiopia has the calm one of the fastest
growing economies on the planet.
During the last decade,
Ethiopia has averaged a growth rate of
around 10% per year.
For example,
check out the following graphic here.
We can compare Ethiopia's GDP growth per
capita with that of another rapidly
growing country,
Vietnam and watch our,
because Ethiopia's population is huge
and as we're talking here about GDP per
capita,
but the hold on a moment,
we're not just talking about the
economy.
As you can imagine,
all of this growth has led to some
important social consequences,
which is something that sooner or later
always happens when a country grows,
opens up to the world and does things
right.
Since the year 2000 the average life
expectancy has increased by 13 years,
the number of workers with at least a
completed secondary education has grown
by almost 50% it's poverty.
Well,
look at what's happening with poverty.
Yup.
I know even today there is a lot of
poverty in Ethiopia with a simple google
search.
We can find terrible situations in this
country,
but folks,
let's be clear.
Overcoming poverty isn't something that
happens overnight.
I mean,
I wish it was that easy,
but it's not.
In any case,
how does ABB above that country's
capital is a good reflection of the
process that Ethiopia is experiencing?
Cranes works and projects of all kinds
are absolutely flooding the city.
In fact,
it was here in this city that their
first light subway in sub Saharan Africa
was inaugurated in 2015 yeah.
Course.
Having reached this point,
the question that we must ask is,
well,
how on earth has Ethiopia achieved such
an economic leap?
What we can say that this country has
become something like Beijing's
outstanding.
Okay,
great.
There's largely been led by essentially
copying the Asian giants.
See,
on the one hand,
the Ethiopian government has promoted
the construction of enormous
infrastructure projects that are
essential for the country's development.
We're speaking,
for example,
all of a railway line,
the cost more than $4 billion in
connected Santa's Salbaba with the
Djibouti port to facilitate and
merchandise exports or the greatest
projects in all of Africa.
The Grand Ethiopian renascence.
Damn.
This is a John Dam on the Nile River
that requires an investment of around $6
billion and his mission with soup
revolutionize the country's energy
system with abundance and cheap
electricity.
By the way,
do you know who gave the investment and
the knowledge for these projects?
Well.
Tony,
those of you who followed this channel
regularly won't be surprised.
To a large extent.
It was China and Chinese company.
In fact,
China has become,
Ethiopia hasn't biggest investor and
trading partner.
In other words,
a large part of the country's growth has
been due to its ties with China.
The second pillar of Ethiopia's growth
is that little by Netapp,
large state owned companies began to
operate with more autonomy and managed
to themselves almost as if they were
private companies.
This is the case for example of
Ethiopian Airlines,
the country's flagship carrier,
which has become the largest African
airline and it's now in,
tends to compete internationally with
the Nigga style lines in the industry.
Even though Ethiopian Airlines is a
hundred percent state owned,
it's run like a business.
The board runs it as if it's British
Airways or United Airlines,
Zuma,
denon nuggets,
chairman of Fairfax,
Africa Fund Llc,
and finally the third pillar thi
attraction of foreign direct investment
through the development of economic
zones,
fiscal incentives,
participative financing,
et cetera.
Take a look at how foreign investments
have evolved.
This is how Ethiopia has begun to
industrialize largely because of these
policies,
and also thanks to the cost of labor and
industry that has grown a lot in recent
years has been textiles.
In fact,
brands such as h and m guest,
Tommy Hilfiger and Calvin Klein already
produced some of that governments in
this country,
but unfortunately that's not all that
similarities with China aren't limited
to the economic part.
Okay.
At the same time that the country was
experiencing an economic takeoff,
does that repression of civil liberties
became stronger and stronger.
The media,
it was broadly restricted.
Political opposition was persecuted
websites,
blogs,
et cetera.
In recent years,
this country became one of the 10
biggest journalist,
jailers,
and the entire wealth.
Ethiopian government virtually locks up,
forced into exile or intimidated almost
every independent journalist.
In other words,
Ethiopia practically reached a situation
in which there were no journalists,
only government spokesman,
but folks,
hold on a moment because now suddenly it
looks like everything has the gun to
change.
Listen Up.
A new generation beginning of 2018
Ethiopia was mired in a way of a
violence,
racial clashes and political repression
that was threatening the country
stability with absolute collapse.
Okay.
And although economically things have
worked out quite well in recent years,
there have been some imbalances are
rather large foreign debt and great
shortage of foreign currency.
As a result of large investments in
population growth and very high,
you found employment rates.
Indeed,
many were wondering if what if eop or
had gone through in recent years have
been nothing but a mirage.
However,
against all odds,
after a high power struggle,
the ruling Party v Ethiopian People's
Revolutionary Democratic Front in
practice,
the only party elected Prime Minister
Abe Akhmed,
a 42 year old former army officer.
Not much was expected,
but within just a few months,
boom.
Things have changed.
You see you since he came to power.
Akhmed has released many political
prisoners.
He has apologized for the government
abuses.
He's announced senior officials of the
intelligence services and the security
forces for having committed state at
terrorism.
He's promoted the peace agreement with
Eritrea.
He's announced her modifications to the
constitution to establish the limitation
of mandate and he's begun to dismantle
the political censorship and asked xcel
journalists to return to the country
Ethiopia unblocks 264 websites and TV
channels,
and not only that,
he has also announced that the
government will deepen the
liberalization of the economy to attract
more investments to the country if
you'll be open this door to the world
with unprecedented privatization plan.
Of course,
as you can imagine,
all of these things haven't been great
for the country's elite since their
answer.
It didn't take long to come.
If you'll be in pm escapes,
grenade attack,
one dead scores hurt on June the 23rd
2018 during a political events in the
heart of Addis Ababa in which the
president wore a Nelson Mandela tee
shirts.
Some trying to put an end to his
political transition.
However they failed and now the prime
minister knows that he has to step on
the accelerator.
Yeah,
Ethiopia dear is,
it's still a very poor country that has
many problems,
political,
social and economic.
However,
the country,
not long ago,
it was considered the most miserable
country on earth.
Now seems to have an opportunity to take
off.
So will it do so well any time you can
answer this question.
And of course at visual politic,
we'll be following the events very
closely.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video.
Please do hit that like button if you
did.
And don't forget to subscribe for brand
new videos.
Also,
don't forget to check out our friends at
the reconsider media podcasts they
provide us with the vocals in this
episode,
the well not mine.
Also,
this channel,
it's made possible because of Patriarchy
and our patrons on that platform.
Please do consider joining them and
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage.
As always.
Thank you for what.